so today we're gonna talk about
rock-paper-scissors and I reckon
everyone knows how to play it this is
beats paper paper covers rock rock
blunts scissors so three studies oh I
thought it blunts them actually if
anything I probably sharpened them right
there's three strategies each one of
them loses once and wins once so it
looks like there's no strategy that you
can play to win but I'm going to show
you about a new paper that's just come
out which gives you some top tips of how
to win so it's a group of Chinese
scientists where they ran an experiment
where they got 360 students to play
games of rock-paper-scissors with one
another 300 rounds in every game which
took up to two hours which is
astonishing students playing what
purposes for two hours okay so normally
if you have rock-paper-scissors and so
you have rock up there and rock is
beaten by paper which is then beaten my
scissors so none of these strategies
dominate the other so really all you can
do is play each strategy with an equal
probability 1/3 1/3 1/3 ok and now if
you were playing against the computer
who is choosing these perfectly randomly
then that would be the best thing for
you to do is just to pick each strategy
with equal probability but the thing is
is that humours are quite predictably
irrational shall we say in the way that
they choose their strategies so in
recording what all of these students did
in playing rock-paper-scissors the
scientists came up with two quite
important findings of how people try and
beat each other ok so the first one is
that people who win tend to repeat their
strategy so for example if I beat you by
playing rock there is a very high chance
or high probability that I will play
Rock again the second time if it worked
once it's going to work again right but
the second thing the second thing they
found out is that losers change well so
this is the thing that you can exploit
essentially so if you know so this gives
us those two strategies that we can use
so the first tip is that if you lose
that means the other person just won
right so let's imagine that the your
opponent won by playing rock now the
chances are that they're going to play
rock again so you should then play a
paper so you just lost on scissors so
you should play paper which means that
basically even though paper beats rock
so that the sort of cycle goes wrong
like there's paper beats Rock and so on
you should go the other way around the
triangle let's imagine that you played
scissors the other person played Rock
what you should do is you should go
backwards around this triangle and play
paper the next time because there's a
high chance that they're gonna play rock
again so that's the first thing
so go backwards I guess or another way
to say it is essentially you've just
played scissors they's played rock so
play the thing that didn't come up in
that if you lose now the second thing is
that if you've just won now they're
going to expect you to play the same
thing again right which means that
they're gonna play the thing that would
be the thing that you just played so you
need to play the thing that would beat
the thing that would beat the thing that
you just played which is equivalent to
say you need to play what they just
played you should play what they just
played yes so let's imagine then you
just won you played Rock right and you
just won on Rock that means that they
played scissors now they're gonna think
that you're going to play Rock again
which means that they're gonna play
paper which means that you should play
scissors and so again you basically end
up going backwards around the triangle
so play what they just played and again
go backwards or an easier way to say it
then it's plain what they just paid so
in general then if you're cycling
through rock paper scissors your best
strategy is to go backwards and go
scissors paper rock and cycle through
that way is this mathematics or is this
psychology is this is what this is I
can't tell if this is like all to do
with probabilities and stuff where it's
just about knowing how humans think well
I think is that a balance of the two so
it's rooted in game theory
which is the mathematics of looking at
decisions and strategies so in any
situation where you're competing against
someone and your best move is dependent
on what the other person is playing you
can frame it in game theory numberphile
is brought to you by the mathematical
sciences Research Institute but this
video has also been sponsored by
Squarespace
Squarespace is a great service for
designing hosting creating your own
websites and as I've probably mentioned
before I use it myself
no matter what you want to do a blog
podcast shop portfolio Squarespace is as
easy as one two three but it's not just
amateurs who benefit from Squarespace
and all that's brilliant templates
they're developer platform will also
give you full control over all the code
letting you tweak the HTML CSS and
JavaScript into your heart's content and
if you like stats and you are watching
numberphile you really like Squarespace
as analytics they're third-party
integrations and they're easy to use
commerce if you'd like to find out more
go to squarespace.com slash numberphile
you can try it all out you can set up
your own site and you can do it all for
free no credit card required and then if
you do like it and decide to opt-in use
the offer code numberphile and you'll
get 10% off so thank you very much to
Squarespace for supporting this video
and thank you to you for watching it